writing this speech has made me examine
my life choices it has made me gain five
pounds it's a good idea to look up from
your phone once in a while wow what a
great room for me to have a heart attack
in I mean it's almost too much to resist
to all the gorgeous students among us
who are beyond the shadow of a doubt
nursing raging hangovers and praying
that this Disney princess keeps the let
it go metaphors to a minimum so I see
you it's graduation season and Hollywood
a-listers have been offering words of
wisdom to college seniors across the
u.s. here's a look at our favorite
moments from their 2019 commencement
speeches starting with Katie Holmes
speaking at the University of Toledo and
I have to say it's so nice to be back
home in Toledo and Ohio native Katie
never attended the school but she did
have Siege advice for graduating seniors
people react to your confidence
I've been tricking folks for years into
believing I'm other characters and I
haven't gotten caught yet
guys it's all fake and speaking of fakes
another thing I learned don't use a fake
ID to buy wine and then try to pay with
a check I'm aware that no one pays by
check these days but that's just more
reason not to do it that'll be extra
confusing
unless President Weinberg left me out of
it seems like I'm gonna give you a
commencement address I guess he couldn't
get Oprah Michelle Obama or anyone real
and so it's gonna be me Jennifer Garner
brought all the laughs to her alma mater
I graduated in 1994 that's one ariana
grande ago complete with these hilarious
life hacks nothing looks better in your
50s than sunscreen in your 20s I know I
know
Neutrogena when it comes to Halloween
costumes go funny over sexy why would
you dress like a flirty nurse when you
could be a mailbox it's a college I have
to tell you that I have agonized over
what I would say to you today Laverne
Cox used a quote from the bell hooks
book yearning language is also a place
of struggle to kick off her powerful
politically charged message about
abortion and inclusion this isn't just
about being politically correct this is
not just about virtue signaling language
that is appropriate in fully inclusive
is a matter of life and death for so
many people out there the energy a
coucher college graduation was electric
thanks to Bill Nye the Science Guy
who talked climate change if you could
and Harry Potter magic
Wanda coal fashion make one sweeping
change to the world that would address
climate change it would be this you
would raise the standard of living for
girls and women worldwide with a touch
of humor and it's good to read the label
on a can of paint before you drink it
Pierce Brosnan referenced James Bond
during his speech at Dickinson College
as someone who has saved the world a few
times or at least played someone who has
I'd like to offer you a bit of advice if
you want to save the world you don't
need to be James Bond
meanwhile Viola Davis used a recent
skydiving trip to
Barnard college grads about leaving a
lasting impression is usually my
Wauconda salute to my sisters so with my
hands up what I'm saying is that on this
day of your Genesis your leap your
commencement your mark in your history
perhaps your elixir is simply this but
you can either leave something for
people or you can leave something in
people I really should get a medal for
crashing and burning because I feel a
lot and that's okay Tori Amos was as raw
as it gets during her address at the
Peabody Conservatory you have a skill
set now you meet the imagination and you
need the Bullock's Bulls balls guys
things will go wrong that's okay
success can be very seductive while
Ellie Kemper continued the honesty at
Princeton maybe you've heard the saying
want to make God laugh make a plan and
left graduates with these parting words
class of 2019 go be nice to one another
and please repair the world that all the
old people here and I have destroyed I'm
serious do it for my son do it for his
sailing team please congratulations to
the class of 2019
[Music]